[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
today we are going to discuss a very
trendy topic
it has made the news and it fills up my
twitter feed these days
and the topic is open ai's gpt gpt3
in this video we will discuss three
things
what is gpt3 what can gpt3 do
we will have some cool apps and examples
and how much do we know or not know
about gpd3
and what potential problems and
limitations might be
let's start with the first question what
is gpt3
no gpt 3 is not a time zone
gpt stands for generative pre-trained
transformer and is more or less a very
cool and sophisticated language or
sequence continuator
the word transformer is referring to the
transformer of 2017
invented by google 2018's gpt
uses the transformer modules and has a
total of
110 million parameters
but 2019's gpt2 brought 1.5
billion parameters to the game the gpt
language model
trained on next word prediction can
generate continuations of text so well
that openai was afraid to release the
model worried that it might be used for
generating deep fakes and false texts to
news
well this is 2020 and this year has
brought us many things
but it has also given us gpt 3
that has no less than 175
billion parameters what will 2021
bring us the gpt-3 architecture
is the same as the predecessors gpt2 and
gpt
only bigger does size matter though
well kind of with many parameters the
model can solve more complicated
problems but with many parameters
one should also train on larger and
larger amounts of training data
to avoid overfitting do you remember
science fiction movies where the ai can
finally connect to the internet and
becomes
extremely powerful reaching the
singularity and surpassing the human
intelligence
well we are not in that situation yet
but we have to acknowledge the sheer
amount of data
the 175 billion parameters were trained
on
gpt3 has more or less seen the whole
internet and this has
implications we do not grasp yet so what
can gpt 3
do after it has seen so much this leads
us to the next part of the video as the
gbt3 paper already said
it's in the title gpt 3 is very good at
few shot learning few shot means that
only very few training examples are
needed to get good performance on the
task
when we were younger who are we kidding
this was a few weeks ago so again
when we were only a little bit younger
we had to fine-tune pre-trained models
like bird or gpd2
on not so small data sets with task
specific annotation
nowadays similar results to fine tuning
can be achieved only by giving to gpt 3
some
few tasks specific examples gpt 3
seems to do it all or can it though
we will discuss this towards the end of
the video
for now let's see where gpt 3 shines
while the paper discussed benchmarks or
not so benchmark cases
we will here see what the community on
twitter could do
with the api of gpd3 if you are
interested to place it yourself you can
request access and hope you get it few
shot is the first topic here in our
showcase
where michael posts about his successful
attempt to convert
legal text into commoners english
by showing only two examples to gpt3 the
model was able to create even more
similar results see for yourself
well you could say that all this is a
very good pattern matching algorithm
which it
more or less is so here is an example of
another kind of pattern matching where
paul katzen created one spreadsheet
function
with gpt3 which can look up state
population
twitter usernames and employers and do
math
needless to say that ai before gpt 3
could
do these things but only after being
trained on lots of such
data and could hardly do all these
things enumerated here
at once not convinced yet we have more
yash build a bot with gpt 3 that
generates financial statements
just amazing
unsurprisingly since it is a language
model gpt
3 is perfect for text completion like
for generating automated answers to
emails so you do not have to write those
yourself anymore do you
emails are perhaps not surprising what
about poetry
preserving verse and ensuring rhymes
i am not so happy about this example in
particular
since i hoped coding was one of the last
things ai would do
but here it is check out these examples
by sharif shameem where gpt 3
is generating code from just
descriptions
of what one wants to do
what about chatbots with impersonation
skills
if you always wanted to chat with elon
musk but he was too busy to chat with
you
you can chat with gpt3 impersonating him
instead
many deep fake storms ahead
this beautiful example used google to
extract the text from
image and then process the text with
gpt3 to extract
ingredients find an emoji determined if
it's unhealthy and give a definition o
m g
g p t 3 can also be a search engine if
you want
are there any limits
one more example this time a funny one
where
merc's mensch cosmopol asked gpt3 about
god he certainly has no questions
anymore
now let us speak about the elephant in
the room coming to our last question
what if this view shot behavior is just
happening because gpt 3 has seen
it all during training and now our tasks
we come up with are not so new to the
model at the end of the day
well we just do not know and emily
bender just
said it i don't find anything
linguistically interesting about massive
language models especially without
detailed information about their
training data
she has a point here especially we need
to know
what all of the training data was when
thinking about
harmful biases like in this example with
really unpleasant results
the huge amount of data means also a lot
of compute power
used during training the gpt 3 paper
says
practical large-scale pre-training
requires large amounts of computation
which is energy intensive training the
gpt-3
consumed several thousands days of beta
flops per second
of compute during pre-training compared
to
tens of days of petaflops per second for
a smaller
gpt-2 model this is a problem for normal
researchers
especially for academia in many
countries where compute resources are
rather scarce
the second problem is of course the
environmental impact
of the energy consumption during long
training sessions
the open ai paper brings a defense point
about
energy consumption the paper says though
models like gpt 3 consume
significant resources during training
they can be surprisingly efficient
once trained even with the full gpt 3
generating 100 pages of content from a
pre-trained model
can cost on the order of 0.4 kilowatt
hour
or only a few cents in energy costs
this is a fair point but we ask
ourselves
what if this training of bigger and
bigger models on even more training data
becomes the trend of the future in
training and developing huge models
consuming lots of energy just goes on
and on
gpt 3 performs so well as seen in the
twitter examples or in the gpt3 paper
on sentence generation machine
translation and so on
so it's normal that the model seems very
very attractive to large-scale industry
and seems like the future will have a
lot of applications with gpt 3
built in them well i do not want to make
anyone worry about this but the gpt3
paper also shows that the model is very
susceptible to
adversarial attacks these attacks show
how problematic
it might be if gpt-3 deployed somewhere
is targeted with malicious adversarial
attacks
more about adversarial attacks in the
next video
well a lot is still to be investigated
here
and i hope that openai will tell us more
about the data
it has trained the model on for a start
if openai becomes more open and grants
wider access to the model
the ai research landscape will certainly
change
just an example during the last years
the frequent and probably the most
annoying paper reviewer question
was why didn't you use bird
miss coffee bean already prepares
herself for the next reviewer question
at conferences why didn't you use gpt 3
anyway until we know more miss coffee
bean seems to agree with this opinion
here
which in our translation sounds like
this gpt
is like a small child that looked at the
whole internet does not understand
anything but can
repeat everything and yearn help good
also delivers an example
where if asked in a certain manner gpt 3
responds that the sun has an
eye a blade of grass has an eye too so
we have seen with this example that
this child does not have a lot of common
sense
only that this child can solve what a.i
has been trying to solve for decades and
this child will become
some kind of an oracle i'm afraid well
these are certainly interesting times to
be alive
you